I had the experience recently of doing
something that was more serious on this
project and hasn't come out yet but I
was very self-conscious about it at
first because it's very different you
know if your whole life is listening for
the laughs and then You' you've got to
inhabit this other space where You' got
to just actually sense if it's working
or if it's not working and it's jelling
and I'm wondering when you first were
switching over did did you feel when you
were doing dramatic Parts did it feel at
all alien to you or was it just like a
duck in water first when I when I first
started yes it felt foreign to me
because it was a muscle that I didn't
get to exercise in my in my craft you
know what I mean I could take a a
multicam script and and read it in the
car at the stoplight and get to work and
already have three choices you know
leave them wanting more you know what I
mean I'mma do this in front of the live
audience I'mma do that for the and I'mma
give them another you know what I mean
because it was such in My DNA but the
other part I never forget honey let's
get back to mama my mama told me she
said now you know what you real funny
and you got that natural you got that
but on that drama side you need some
work you you you you don't do that too
good so here's what mama's going to do
wow she said that to you she said I'mma
work
overtime okay to get the money you find
the best class in town and I'm GNA pay
for it cuz if you going to do it you do
it right what my mother said that's
incredible that's when I went somewhere
and tried to figure it out and I was so
lucky that I found then a class where
you used to bring a VHS children that's
a videotape um there were these
machines but you you you could take it
the old days they were a big brick
that's what I had the old days that just
the the big quarter inch I mean it was
it was or 3/4 inch I think it was a big
it was like a piece of concrete that was
that was your right on up in there and I
would go back home and just watch it and
see what I could do different and try to
you know try to watch it but now you can
also because you know what we look for
we we're looking for the reaction to
make sure we did the bit but you see it
in the face of the crew you see it when
you when you do a scene and you know if
it's popping or not when the crew is
like yeah you know what I mean or they
choke up you know what I mean walk off
you know the when they stop eating for a
second the fried bread you know you got
them that's it that's it when they drift
away from the craft Food Service table
you know you got them that part yeah I
always used to try and I mean this
always relates more to Comedy but when I
was working on anything I would I knew
that if the like if it was at a venue
where there's like weight staff for
anybody if they're hanging out watching
and they seem to be chuckling that meant
more to me than anything like I felt
like okay these are people that aren't
they're not here to laugh they don't
have to laugh they don't even have to
listen but it's a it's a very different
vibe but but yeah it's interesting that
you mentioned that with the crew like
they're people and they will pick up and
they see a lot they see every they see
people come and go oh yeah and you can
see if they if you've got them that
really means something it means
something who was I'm just curious what
kind of acting classes did you take was
what was the was there a certain method
that you were learning or um I don't
even remember the the teacher or
anything I just remember taking a class
where you had to bring your your
videotape in yeah every week and then
you know they would tape you and then
you know watch it back and critique you
and tell you all of the things and then
I just kept I just kept trying and
trying and trying and I really just felt
like I wanted to get it right and um uh
where it turned a corner for me was this
the series that I did on HBO called
getting on yeah that was where it turned
the corner because even though it was a
comedy I guess a workplace comedy
interesting because I love the show but
it's also it's so funny because we're in
this new world now where I think it's
harder and harder to label things a
comedy or a drama because getting on
could be really funny but also very
touching and then just heartbreaking so
I don't know what you would call it but
yeah but it it was playing I was always
so broad all of my bits all of my stuff
that I had done before that were always
so Broad and this was so small so panimo
so to me it it very much felt like if
you play the scene for real It's a drama
for me you you you play it for real you
don't play it for the joke and you say
it with as much of a straight face you
not not waiting for the BP bump you you
you just the lines are just rolling into
the next one and I was like oh boy this
this
is and I I remember the producer coming
in he says Hey listen I know you've
never done anything like this before but
if you play your cards right you lady
will be on the e- list and I thought my
God Kathy Griffin is on the D list
what's lower than that what what do I
want to be on the
eist you'll someday maybe get up to
Kathy Griffin's level weird thing for
someone to say El but then I find he
kept talking and I was sitting there
just about to cry and I was like I he
really thinks he doesn't think that much
of me and he said because when you get
nominated for that Emy I said oh
El yes I got it yeah I got it now I was
like yeah but that was after I died
inside
and he was right you know and I and I
got the nominations so he was right you
know what's cool too about that show is
it uh put a spotlight on we have such a
we our culture just so avoids older
people and so avoids you know and and to
a point where if you look at ads and you
drive around you just look at magazines
and everything you'd think that old
people didn't even exist and it's it's
for a to actually make the whole Focus
about that the elderly the elderly and
that St that stage of life but then also
I think that's why the humor was such a
relief on the show you could create that
tension and then things were that much
funnier to me because oh yeah you're
dealing with such a a third rail topic
one of one of my the ladies in the show
that I was in a scene with and they they
kept trying to yell and tell her she was
talking too loud and he said what and
she tell her she talking too loud and I
said well he just wants me to let you
know you're talking you know too loud
you could you could talk a little softer
oh that comes from my years in vaudville
dear I was like
okay that's awes I said all right that's
awesome so at lunchtime we talked about
VV I tell me everything I killed it in